[Music]
javascript is a programming language
that people love to hate a long time ago
developers used to pride themselves on
being back in developers because it was
more challenging and complex javascript
was just a toy for annoying people on
websites but it's 2019 and today we have
tools like the cloud docker and many API
is that abstract way the complexity of
back-end development if you're starting
up a company today there's a good chance
you'll do the majority of your
development on the front end with
JavaScript so today I want to show you
how to write good JavaScript with modern
features and avoid bad JavaScript if
you're just finding me like and
subscribe and if you have your own
JavaScript pro tips let me know in the
comments one lucky comment will win this
one-of-a-kind t-shirt via livestream
next week
so the first thing you need to know is
how to debug your JavaScript like a pro
and the way we do that of course is by
console logging stuff and I'm saying
that with a straight face there are good
ways to console log and bad ways let's
imagine we have three different objects
each one assigned to its own variable
the obvious way to log these is just one
after the other but the main problem is
we don't know the name of the variable
when this gets logged but there's a
trick we can use here called computed
property names where we add the
variables to an object not only does
this reduce the code footprint but it
also tells us exactly which variable
define this data one line of code one
console log and all the information we
need but maybe this data is extra
important so we want to make it stand
out with some custom CSS styling you can
substitute data and also CSS styles by
using a percent sign so we'll add
percent C and then have the second
argument be our actual CSS style and now
we get this bold orange color in the
console one thing you might have noticed
is that the objects all share common
properties so maybe we could display
those as a table this is really useful
when you have an array of objects just
do console table with the array I could
probably do a whole video on console
logging so I'll just show you a couple
more things here if you're benchmarking
performance you can actually keep track
of time in the console will first define
our timer and we'll give it a name of
looper then we'll set up a while loop
and we'll go through a million
iterations in that loop when that's done
we'll run console time and as you can
see here it takes an average of about 4
to 5 milliseconds to loop a million
times
keeping track of time is great but what
if you need to know where a console.log
originated from let's imagine we have a
really important function that deletes
items from our database and we want to
make sure that we don't accidentally
call this method twice you can add a
console trace to your function and it
will give you a stack trace for where it
was called and what defined it if we run
this code we'll get a console log that
tells us the function was defined on
line 35 and then called on lines 37 and
38 so now that you're a debugging expert
I'm going to show you a few different
ways you can make your code as concise
and efficient as possible let's imagine
we have an object with some animal data
and we need a function that will tell us
how to feed the animal this is just a
function that returns a string so inside
that string will interpolate a few
values from that object this doesn't
look too bad but you'll notice that
we're repeating the word animal over and
over again there's a technique called
object D structuring that we can use to
eliminate most of the repetition here if
we have a function that takes an object
but we only need to use a handful of its
properties we can D structure those in
the argument itself we just wrap it in
brackets and then pass in the names of
the object properties that we want to
use so now we can format the same string
but we never actually have to use the
word animal directly this might seem
like a modest gain on this simple
function but when you have a big object
with a lot of properties this can make a
huge difference and I completely
understand that some people don't like
that bracket syntax in the object
argument so there's actually another way
we can do this which is just as good
this time we pass in the animal object
like we did originally but then we set
up a variable that has the names of the
properties in that object set equal to
the object and now we can use those
properties like variables throughout the
function and this tends to be the better
way to go if you have multiple objects
2d structure and a single function the
next thing we'll look at is template
literals which we've already been using
in the code but there's more to talk
about here when I first started
programming about 10 years ago
jQuery was the cool thing in JavaScript
kind of like react is today but
unfortunately it didn't have all of the
awesome things that we have in
JavaScript now for example you would see
a lot of string concatenation that looks
like this where you have a variable plus
a string and you have to manage the
spaces in between plus an expression
plus a whole bunch of other stuff this
type of code is
incredibly annoying to deal with but
template literals in modern JavaScript
solve this problem completely
instead of concatenating values together
we can actually interpolate them
directly into the string you can do this
by defining your string with backticks
and then use dollar sign brackets and
then whatever variable or expression you
want inside up there so we'll go ahead
and grab the properties we need with
object D structuring that we learned
just a minute ago
and then we'll interpolate those into
the string itself which is a lot more
readable and a lot easier to maintain
but you can actually take things a step
further and build strings in a purely
functional way so we'll write a function
here called horse age that takes in
array of strings as the first argument
and then it can take whatever other
arguments that wants after that we can
look at the arguments to this function
and use them to compose a string so here
we're going to look at the age of the
animal and if it's older than five we'll
say it's old otherwise we'll say it's
young and the last thing we'll do is
return the actual value of the string
that's a pretty standard looking
function but the interesting thing here
is that instead of passing a regular
argument to this function we can
actually just attach it to a template
literal and it will parse the arguments
in it this might seem kind of weird at
first but instead of doing parentheses
with the arguments we'll just attach our
template literal and it will parse all
of the string segments as an array of
strings as the first argument to the
function that we defined then it will
handle all the other arguments in the
order in which they appear inside of the
dollar sign brackets in other words you
can take a single argument and use it to
compose multiple values in the return
string this can be a very powerful
concept for templating and it's actually
used in the polymer project now via a
library called lit HTML so now that we
know how to work with strings we're
going to move on to the spread syntax to
work with objects and arrays let's
imagine we have one object for a Pokemon
and the other one for the stats that
define its various attributes let's say
we want to assign the properties from
the stats object to the Pikachu object
one way to do that is to just redefine
them one by one on the original Pikachu
object for one this is just really ugly
and verbose but we're also mutating the
original object when we most likely want
to create a new immutable object because
let's say that our Pokemon
levels up over time we want to represent
each level up as its own object we could
use object to sign here and take the
original object and merge it in with the
stats and this will merge them together
from left to right or if we just wanted
to update a single property we could add
an object with that property in it this
isn't too bad but there's a more concise
way to do this with the spread syntax by
creating a new object and placing our
existing objects in it with three dots
in front of them it will compose a new
object from left to right so the
property is farthest to the right will
have the priority again this is mostly
just syntactic sugar and it just makes
your code more readable and easier to
maintain and it's also possible to use
the spread syntax on arrays so let's
imagine we have an array of strings and
we need to push additional items to this
array the old-school way to do this
would be to just push new items to the
array one by one but in today's world we
can reduce these three lines of code to
just one by defining an array with the
new items and in the spread syntax on
the original array if we add the three
dots to the beginning then it's the
equivalent of doing an array push
because it will append the new items to
the end of the array but the nice thing
is we could just add this to the end of
the array and then we have the
equivalent of a race shift and we might
even take the original values and just
splice them in the middle of the array
giving us even more flexibility and this
code brings back some memories you see
this little trailing comma here this
used to be the kind of thing that would
break an entire JavaScript program and
be really difficult to figure out but
luckily in modern JavaScript it just
works and it's actually kind of
considered a good practice because you
can reduce the number of lines that
change when you do get commits now it's
time to move on to loops let's imagine
we have an array of numbers here that
represent the order totals that we've
had throughout the day in our app now
let's say we need to compute some values
based on this array such as the order
total maybe we need to add some tax to
each one and filter out the high value
orders to be reviewed by a manager one
option is to just use a classic for loop
like you'll find in pretty much every
programming language we have an integer
that starts at zero while that integer
is less than the orders length we will
increment it by one
personally I hate loops that look like
this and I almost never use them in
JavaScript but while we're in the loop
we can start computing
values for the total we will just do
plus equals with the order total then to
create a new array with the tax added to
it we'll go ahead and take the order
amount and multiply it by 1.1 to add 10%
tax then if we have order values that
are greater than 100 we'll go ahead and
add those to the high value order array
this code is a very ugly and B it's
mutating values that might make our code
a little more unpredictable luckily we
can reduce this down to just three lines
of code by using modern JavaScript array
methods if we want to take an array and
then have it accumulate to a value that
equals say a total amount we can use
array reduce it takes a callback
function as the argument where the first
argument is the accumulated value and
the second argument is the current value
in the loop so if we want to sum up all
of the items in the array we can just do
the accumulated values plus the current
value and when the loop finishes that
will give us the total of all elements
in that array mapping and filtering
values is even easier if we want to add
tax to all the items in the array we can
just take the values in the array then
map them to their value times 1.1 and
lastly we can use filter to create an
array that only has the values greater
than 100 in it whenever the callback
function equals true it's going to allow
a value through so in other words if the
value is greater than 100 it will allow
that value through to the new array I
wanted to save the best for last and
that of course is async/await let's
create a method called random that
returns a promise that resolves to a
random number asynchronously now let's
imagine that we want to retrieve three
different asynchronous numbers one after
the other and then add them all together
at the end that might seem like a silly
example but that's actually how things
work a lot of times in the real world
when you have to retrieve one item from
the database get some data retrieving
another item from an API and so on with
promises you wait for an asynchronous
value to resolve and then you handle it
with a callback function inside of then
once you have your data you can return
another promise and then chain another
then call back to it and continue this
pattern on for as long as you need to
you end up with this ridiculous looking
code where you keep saying and then
and then and then but fortunately
there's a really nice solution to this
which is async/await
basically it allows us to express a
singer s code in a synchronous format we
can come down here and rewrite our
promise chain the only difference is
adding async in front of the function
which will force it to return a promise
but the real benefit here is that we can
use a weight in front of our promises
and have them resolve to an actual
variable value so instead of using those
then callbacks we can just say Const
first equals await random and do the
same thing for the second and third
number and now it's much easier to read
and understand this code because we can
just go line by line and see that we're
waiting one number awaiting another
number and so on
a sync wait is one of the most awesome
things to ever happen to JavaScript and
it really deserves its own video right
now we're out of time but in the future
I'll show you some of the cool things
you can do with it like use it in
conditional statements or use it in for
loops and things like that I'm gonna go
ahead and wrap things up there if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and make sure to check out the
livestream next week to see if you want
some free swag and if you're serious
about building apps consider becoming a
pro member at angular firebase comm
you'll get all kinds of exclusive
content designed to help you build and
ship your app faster thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you soon